I'M GONNA.
START THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JUST TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM WE'RE NOT GONNA BEGIN
READING BILLS UNTIL WE GET A
REPUBLIC MY REPUBLICAN VICE
CHAIR HERE. BUT MADAM SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE ARM CULTURAL.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PRESIDENT
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHAO.
EGGMAN.
FONG.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
IS THERE ANY.
PRESIDENT OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK HERE BRASS HERE
NOTICE WE'RE WAITING FOR THE.
REPUBLICAN VICE CHAIR THAT WE
HAVE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
BILLS ON SUSPENSE THAT'S THE
LARGEST WE'VE HAD LEAST IN A
DECADE.
BOTH FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
I'M SORRY.
YES EVEN MORE.
AND I'D REALLY LIKE TO GET HOME
TO MY KIDS.
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS KEEPING ME
FROM BEING A FAMILY VALUES KIND
OF PERSON TODAY.
MISTER OBERNOLTE ENOUGH
PRESSURE.
HILL SERVICE THE.
SIT IN FOR THE VICE CHAIR AND WE
CAN BEGIN.
I WANT TO THANK.
.
MY STAFF THE THE APPROPRIATIONS
STAFF AND MY COLLEAGUES IN THEIR
STAFFER TAKING THIS SO
SERIOUSLY.
THAT THE REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT
HAS WHILE I'M MY VICE CHAIR.
.
I'M SURE IS ON HIS WAY OUT AND
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD WITHOUT IN
START.
JUST IN TIME.
YEAH.
I WAS JUST THINKING MY VICE
CHAIR IS THERE ANY COMMENTS YOU
WANT TO MAKE MISTER BIGELOW IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
WITH THAT.
GUESS THEY CAN'T REALLY READ
WITHOUT IN HERE IRATE ARE WE
READY.
START WITH LABOR.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE SALAS
VALLEY FEVER HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS.
HOLD IN COMMITTEE.
THAT'S OKAY.
WE'LL DO THAT ONE MORE TIME.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE SALAS
VALLEY FEVER HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS HOLD IN COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY RADIUS
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AND
COMPLAINTS I HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY MISS
FRIEDMAN.
THAT GETS OUT WITH.
THE REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WAS UPS TO THE
MOTION SECOND FOR ALL DO PASS OR
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE
REST OF THE SUSPENSE FILE.
ALRIGHT YOU READY GUYS.
AB NINETEEN OF CHU LEVINE
PERSONAL SERVICES CONTRACT
HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B. NINETEEN
TWELVE RODRIGUEZ JPA RETIREMENT
OBLIGATIONS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN.
THIRTEEN KALRA FOR LABOR
CONTRACTORS DO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN SIXTEEN
COOPER ETHNIC AND GENDER PAY
DISPARITIES DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REQUIRE THE REPORT TO BE
COMPLETED EVERY TWO YEARS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN SANTIAGO
PAYROLL DEDUCTION.
DAY PASSED THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FORTY NINE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN NINE BONTA
MEDICAL CANNABIS ACCOMMODATION
ARE WE DON'T WORK.
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER JANITORIAL WORKERS IN
TRAINING PROGRAM DO PASS ON A.
B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SIXTY THURMOND PART
TIME PLAYGROUND POSITIONS DO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE FRIEDMAN
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE RODRIGUEZ
POLICE OFFICERS AND PURDUE
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING.
AB TWENTY THIRD 23-14 TEAM
DOMESTIC WORKERS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM UPON APPROPRIATION AND
NO LONGER REQUIRE THE CREATION
OF SPECIFIED ENFORCEMENT
POSITIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN EGGMAN
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS FOR
STATE LOCAL INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO NARROW THE BILL TO APPLY ONLY
TO PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR AT
THURMOND OCCUPATIONAL INJURIES
AND ILLNESS DATABASE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE THE STATE
DATABASE CONTINGENT ON SPECIFIC
FEDERAL ACTIONS THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT
LEVINE TRAINING STANDARDS FOR
TALENT AGENCIES DO PASS AS
AMENDED AMENDED TO INCLUDE A FEE
FOR THE COSTS OF TRAINING. THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING TWENTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT CARILLO ANTI
DISCRIMINATION POLICIES AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS DO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTEEN CALDERON PURSE POSITIONS
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE VOEPEL
INFINITE WORK PROGRAMS DO YOU
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY SIX
THIRTEEN RAY S. PENALTIES FOR
FAILURE TO PAY WAGES DO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
RODRIGUEZ MO YOU APPROVAL DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN RODRIGUEZ
TRAFFICKING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRACKING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STINGING.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE MARK
STONE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SET TIMELINES FOR THE
BOARD TO PROCESS FINAL BOARD
ORDERS IT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY THIRTY RADIUS COUNTY
INTERN HIRING PROGRAM DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE EACH COUNTY
DEVELOP A HIRING PROGRAM CLARIFY
GROUPS THAT MAY BE GIVEN HIRING
PREFERENCE. AND WE WILL REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT A
PARTICIPANT BE CONSIDERED FOR
PAID POSITION PACKETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY RUBIO
PILOT PROGRAM FOR ADULTS WITH
AUTISM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SICK LEAVE
EXPANSION HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
SANTIAGO LIMITED TERM LAW CLERK
DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN CAMBIADO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
MUTUAL AID ASSISTANCE TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX KALRA
RETALIATION COMPLAINTS TO PASS
ON TO BE ABLE ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE KALRA
BLOOD LEVEL. BLOOD LEAD LEVELS
REPORTING TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
RADIUS LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S AND PUBLIC
CONTRACTING HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTEEN LOW SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
IT B. THIRTY EIGHTY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION ENFORCEMENT DO
PASS AS AMENDED WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS GETS OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX BONTA
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS.
HOLDEN COMMITTEE BUT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT EVERYTHING THAT IS
IN THAT BILL HAS.
.
BEEN TRANSFERRED TO THE NEXT
BILL AB THIRTY EIGHTY ONE BY
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND BONTA NOW
EMPLOYMENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ELIMINATE THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR HOTLINE EXPAND.
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS TO
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THEIR FAMILIES IN AB MISTER
BONTA AS A JOINT AUTHORED THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY FOUR LEVINE
OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
REPORTS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE SALAS
DISABILITY INSURANCE DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINED.
AB THIRTY TO TWENTY TWO
O'DONNELL PREVAILING WAGES AND
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT TO PASS
SOME OF THE ROLL CALL.
OKAY.
GENERAL GOVERNMENT'S GONNA BE
NEXT
.
ALRIGHT GENERAL GOVERNMENT
READY.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR SALAS
STATE ROUTE ONE EIGHT AFFORD
RELINQUISHMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE BLOOM
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO STREAMLINE THE REVISION
REQUEST AN APPEALS PROCESS MAKE
OTHER MINOR CHANGES BACK IT'S
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE STEINORTH
ONLINE CORPORATE STATEMENTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT TO SCHOOL BUS SEAT
BELTS DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN IS THERE AN
EARTHQUAKE BUILDING STANDARDS TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO
GRANTS FOR IMMIGRATION SERVICES
DO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE OBERNOLTE
DRIVERS LICENSE VETERANS
DESIGNATION DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR VOEPEL
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE TRUST FUND
FUNDING HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHAT
CONNECTING HOMOS OWNERS TO
EXTENDED REPLACEMENT COST
COVERAGE DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN LIMON
TRANSLATION OF EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RESTRICT BILLS
REQUIREMENTS TO PUBLIC FACING
COMMUNICATIONS PACKETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB EIGHTEEN SIX EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX CARILLO SPECIAL ELECTIONS
HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY EIGHT MATHIS CALTRANS
PROPERTY LEASES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE LOW. CONSOLIDATE DEBRIS
REMOVAL PROGRAMS HOLDING
COMMITTEE OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE BONTA TAX EXEMPTION FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR EDUARDO GARCIA
MUSEUMS FOR ALL GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWO THOUSAND SIX EGGMAN VAN
PULL GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE REFERENCES TO
THE G. G. ARE A FUND. THAT GETS
OUT WITHIN A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR KALRA
EMPLOYEE TRAINING ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE
YEAR. CLARIFY WHO GUIDELINES ARE
DESIGNED FOR EXCEPT AGENCIES
THAT HAVE EXISTING TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN REQUIRED DOJ TO ALSO
CONSULT WITH EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS IN MASS TRANSIT
SYSTEMS. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX DALY WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FRAUD
REPORTING THAT GETS OUT WITHIN A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SHOT HOLE
BORDER BEETLE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA REHABILITATION OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS TO PASS THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT CHAO CANNABIS
DO YOU AYE STATISTICS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RECAST EXISTING DO
YOU AYE LAWS TO ALLOW FOR
REPORTING THROUGH EXISTING
METHODS. RATHER THAN CREATE A
NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENT THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE FRAZIER WEIGHT
LIMITS FOR NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE REFERENCE TO INTERSTATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SIXTY FIVE TEAM THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA BID PREFERENCE
INCREASE FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TILL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE ACOSTA
GOLD STAR FAMILY LICENSE PLATES
TO PASS WITH ON ANY ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT TO.
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES DO PASS AS
AMENDED RICK RICK TO REINSTATE
THE CHILD SUPPORT PROVISIONS
THAT'S DAVID CHIU I PROBABLY
SHOULD CLARIFY ON THESE.
AB BACK AT THAT WOULD BE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
OBERNOLTE REPORT ON NON
COMPETITIVE BID CONTRACT
REQUESTS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE DAVID
CHIU HOMELESS INTEGRATED DATA
WAREHOUSE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ADD THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO LISTA PARTICIPATING STATE
AGENCIES CLARIFY THE TYPE OF
DATA BE COLLECTED AND STRENGTHEN
THE PRIVACY PROVISIONS THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FIVE LOW ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SIX COMING AT
ALL CALIFORNIA FARM BILL HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO LEVINE ONLINE DATA PRIVACY
INFORMATION. TO PASS AS AMENDED
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
STRIDE STRIKE EXISTING LANGUAGE
AND INSTEAD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO POST LINKS ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE TO ONLINE
IN SOCIAL MEDIA PRIVACY
INFORMATION THAT GETS OUT WITH
THE ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR DAVID
CHIU BUSINESS LICENSES DO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE. I'M SORRY TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT MULLIN CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURES TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN BERMAN
BALLOT TRACKING DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE SECRETARY
STATE USE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL TO THE EXTENT
AND ONLY IF FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE.
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR MULLIN
NARROW TRACKED VEHICLES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. TWENTY OF FIFTY TWO
LIMON STATE GRANT ADMINISTRATOR
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL TWENTY
FIFTY COVER YET ALASKA GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL. TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT REYES
VLF ADJUSTMENTS FOR YOUR CITY
ANNEXATIONS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY TWO MAYES
STATE ROUTE. ONE ELEVEN
RELINQUISHMENT TO PASS ON ANY
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX.
BURKE. AUTO BODY LABOR RATE
SURVEYS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENSURE SURVEYS ARE STATISTICALLY
VALID AND RANDOM ENSURE THAT THE
STATUTORY METHODOLOGY RECEIVES
THE SAME STATUS AS A REGULATORY
METHODOLOGY. MODIFY PROVISIONS
RELATED TO THE GEOGRAPHY TO USE
OF LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AREA BOUNDARIES WITH INTENT TO
READ FURTHER REFINE THESE
BOUNDARIES. DELETE A PROVISION
ALLOWING INSURERS TO LOWER LABOR
RATES SPECIFY THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXAMINATION AUTHORITY AND OTHER
MINOR TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINED.
AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR OBERNOLTE
COURT REQUEST FOR INVESTIGATIONS
OF CHILD ABUSE ALLEGATION THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE OR FOUR HOLDEN
REDUCE FAIR TRANSIT PASS STUDIES
OTHER THAN TO PASS ON AND IT
WILL CALL AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE WHAT BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH
SERVICES IN EMERGENCIES YOU PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY FIVE
TEAMS SMALL BUSINESS INTERESTS
AND SENATE PROGRAM TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE AND CLEAR BY THE RULE
OF FEDERAL FUNDING. PACKETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SIX SALAS SCHOOL
BUS RETROFIT REPLACEMENT TO PASS
IS AMENDED TO READ. MOVE THAT
GIGI ARAFAT AS THE FUNDS WERE
SECOND THOUGHT ON A B. ROLL
CALL.
AB WENTY THREE FORTY THREE
DAVID CHIU EVICTION PROCEEDINGS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
WAVERED REIMBURSEMENT
REQUIREMENT THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY OBERNOLTE
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY ACCOUNTS DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY TWO LOW REPORTABLE
ERRORS DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY FOUR RUBIO
COURT REPORTERS A CHILD CUSTODY
AND AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HEARINGS DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
FRIEDMAN VISIONS ZERO TASK FORCE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO CHANGE
DATES BY WHICH THE TASK FORCE
MUST BE CONVENE IN THE REPORT
PROVIDED THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY CALDERON
ON MY NOTARY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE ONLINE NOTARIES TO
NOTIFY THE SECRETARY STATE
REGARDING THEIR USE A THIRD
PARTY VENDOR PLATFORMS.
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX
MONTH AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS OF STEAM.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
OBERNOLTE ELECTRIC AT ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CENTER
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN IRWIN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT WHO CAN
BE IT. THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER AND CAP TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDING TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
AGUIAR-CURRY PRIVATELY
CONTRACTED FIRE PREVENTION
RESOURCES DO PASS ON IN A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
FIVE CALDERON CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH GUARANTY ASSOCIATION
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN MULLIN
TRANSPORTATION MERGING EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY GRANT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY THREE
SALAS CALTRANS INSPECTION
TESTING SERVICES DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
SIX OBERNOLTE APPROPRIATION FOR
JUDGESHIPS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR
STEINORTH PROTECT OUR HOMES
PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE QUIRK
SILVA COMPETITIVE GRANTS FOR
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS DO PASS ON
ANY WORLD PROBLEM. AB TWENTY
FORTY
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY GRAYSON
ESTABLISHES THE INVASIVE SPECIES
COUNCIL DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ADD MEMBERS CITY COUNCILMEN
STATUS INVASIVE SPECIES FUND
THAT IT'S OUT ON IN IRAQ CALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE
BONTA STATE RIP ONE EIGHTY FIVE
RELINQUISHMENT TO PASS ON ANY
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
ONE COOLEY VLF ADJUSTMENTS FOR
NEW CITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY TWO SALAS
MEDIUM DUTY TRUCK RETROFITTING
REPLACEMENT GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED KALRA
SMALL DOLLAR LOANS AND INTEREST
RATES DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FIVE A THREE IRWIN
DISSOLUTION OF CORPORATIONS A
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES TO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL. TWENTY
FIVE.
I TO BE ROLL CALL I'M SORRY.
TWENTY FIVE OH SIX BURKE STEEP
FLEET HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE WRONG.
IT'S HOLD.
YOU KNOW THAT I WANT TO GO BACK
NOW BECAUSE.
TO AB TWENTY FIVE A THREE OUR
WHEN KNOW THAT WAS RIGHT COVER
WAS A BE RECALL IRWIN
DISSOLUTION OF CORPORATIONS LET
ME TO LIE BILL COMPANIES. THAT
PASSED ON IN A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE A SIX BURKE WAS HELD
IN COMMITTEE ALRIGHT.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SIX IRWIN
CROWD FUNDING FOR CHARITIES
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO MULLIN EACH CD LOANS
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE LOW
BEER MANUFACTURES AND GLASSWARE
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. DAVID
CHIU OF SAN FRANCISCO SHORELINE
PROTECTION DISTRICT TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT KANSEN
CHU FIRE SAFETY MOBILE HOMES DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL INSPECTION
PROVISIONS ACT IT'S OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL. TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX COOLEY CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIC ACTION
PLAN. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT THE SCOPE AND FEEDBACK
REQUIREMENTS THE COMMISSION
STUDY ALLOW GOBIZ TO SEEK
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING FOR THE
STUDY IN ELIMINATE ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORTS ON THE ACTION
PLAN. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY SIX OH SEVEN BERMAN
MEDICAL FOSTER HOMES FOR
VETERANS HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN CUT A DEAL
BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN ACCESS TO
PARKS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
HOME. TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN BONTA
MANDATORY LANDLORDS WITH
CERTIFICATION HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE WORD
TEMPORARY CANNABIS RETAIL
LICENSES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT SMALL LICENSEES AND
SPECIFY TEMPORARY RETAIL
LICENSES. ARE AVAILABLE PER
LICENSEE PACKETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY FIVE GLORIA
MINOR MINOR VEHICLE INFRACTIONS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY CALDERON
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY WORKING
GROUP TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY TWO CHANNEL
RESEARCH ON ELECTRONIC MEDIA IN
CHILD DEVELOPMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX MEDINA
MONITORING EFFECTIVENESS OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SIX ANYONE FONG STATEWIDE
REGULATION REVIEWS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SIX
GIPSON JUNK DEALERS A RECYCLER
RECYCLERS LICENSES DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE IS THERE
AN INVENTORY OF BUILDINGS WITH
SEISMIC VULNERABILITIES TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
DEFINITIONS EXTEND TIMES OF
BILLS REQUIREMENTS REMOVE SOME
REQUIREMENTS FOR BUILDING OWNERS
AND AT OTHER CLEAR FINE
PROVISIONS ACT IT'S OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX A SEVEN QUIRK SILVA
ADDITION NULL DUTIES TO OFFICE
TO SMALL BUSINESS DID PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. TWENTY SEVEN OH SEVEN
MULLIN VOTER INFORMATION WEBSITE
YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL TWENTY
SEVEN ELEVEN CHEN WATCH COUNTY
PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATIONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
AGUIAR-CURRY YOUNTVILLE VETERANS
HOME HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT CHAO ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO LIMIT THE PILOT TO FIGHT
COUNTIES MAKE OTHER CHANGES LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE BONTA MOBILE
FRIENDLY STATE WEBSITES DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO DEFINE MOBILE
FRIENDLY BACK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN REYES
COURT THE. COURT REPORTER FEES
DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THURMOND HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
GRANTS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY IRWIN CAL
THAT INTERNAL AUDITS OFFICE TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL TWENTY OH TO
FRIEDMAN INSURANCE PAYOUTS
INTERCEPTION FOR CHILD SUPPORT
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN FLORA PILOT
PROGRAM FOR FIRE FIGHTING
EQUIPMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY TWELVE LOW MOAN
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGICAL LOOK
TECHNOLOGY LOCAL ASSISTANCE
OFFICE HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY
THIRTEEN IRWIN CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER DO PASS.
ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR GRAY OFFICE A
PROBLEM GAMBLING FUNDING HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
DEBT COLLECTIONS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX GLORIA
REPATRIATION OF NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS FROM YOU SEE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SUNSET REQUIRED
AUDITS AFTER TWO TWO YEAR AUDIT
CYCLES. THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FIFTY ONE GRAYSON TRAFFIC
SIGNAL OPTIMIZATION PLANS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION A LOCAL MANDATE.
REQUIRE CALTRANS TO WORK WITH
CITIES ON EXISTING TRAFFIC
SIGNAL TIMING EFFORTS CHECK IT
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE DAVID
CHIU STATE ROUTE ONE A ONE AND.
TRUE EIGHTY HOT LANES TO PASS ON
A TO BE ROLL CALL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN MATHIS MEDICAL
VEHICLE REPLACEMENT GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY
EIGHTY SEVEN HAD AGUIAR-CURRY
MIGRANT FARM LABOR CENTER IS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY TEAM EXCEPT THREE
DWELLING UNITS TO PASS AS
AMENDED MAKING TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING
TWENTY NINE OH SIX MELENDEZ
NOTICE A DRIVER LICENSE
SUSPENSION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE OH NINE WOULD
REGISTRATION PROGRAM FOR SMALL
SCALE POULTRY PRODUCERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY THREE DAVID CHIU
BART TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT TO PASS ON OF YOU
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SANTIAGO
FICTION PILOT PROGRAMS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL BETWEEN NINE FIVE
FIFTY THREE LOW MOAN TITLE LOANS
IN INTEREST RATES DO PASS ON ED.
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY STATE SHARE COSTS
FOR DEAD AND DYING TREES
EMERGENCY HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE TO ANYONE CALDERON
STATE AGENCY REVIEW REGULATIONS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR LIMON ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
FINANCING LAWS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE FLORES
STAND UP ELECTRIC SCOOTERS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO BROWN THE
TYPES OF ENTITIES THAT MAY
REGULATE ELECTRIC SCOOTERS AND
MAKE A TECHNICAL CORRECTION THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY TEN LIMON PAYDAY
LENDING DATABASE DO PASS WITH B.
ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY TWENTY ONE LEVINE
PATRIE STANDARDS FOR HEN
CONFINEMENT TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE USE OF FEES TO
FUND ADMINISTRATION FOR SOME OF
THE SPELLS PROVISION THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN DAVID
CHIU REDEVELOPMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE
GLORIA REGISTRATION FOR MASSAGE
ESTABLISHMENT OWNERS TO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL. AB THIRTY SIXTY
EIGHT DALY INDEPENDENT LEGAL
COUNSEL FOR COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLERS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTY SEVENTY NINE
O'DONNELL PORT EFFICIENCY GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE CALDERON
NEW BEGINNINGS HOUSING PROGRAM
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO CAP THE
ANNUAL GRANT AT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN MAKE THE PROGRAM
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. THAT GETS OUT
ON A BUREAU CALL. AB THIRTY
NINETY SEVEN SALAS SMOG CHECK
REPORTING TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT GETS OUT A MINI
ROLE CALL. AB THIRTY ONE HUNDRED
FLORA MENINGITIS PRESUMPTION FOR
FIREFIGHTERS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
A. B. THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SAN DIEGO
AIRPORT MOBILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE BILL DOES
NOT LESSEN THE FORTIES
OBLIGATION TO ADDRESS IMPACT
FROM THE AIRPORT DEVELOPMENT
PLAN THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER STATUE LIMITATIONS FOR
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT DO
PASSED.
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ CITY POMONA PROPERTY
CONVENIENCE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE. BONTA
CALTRANS PROP RELEASES IN
OAKLAND DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
PARCELS THAT GETS OUT ON TO BE
WELCOME.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE LOW
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
SUNSET REVIEW DO PASS ON AND HE
ROLL CALL.
THIRTY ONE FORTY FOUR LOW
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY HE'S
BUREAU SUNSET REBOOT REVIEW DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN COMING AT
A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FEE
DISCLOSURES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE SALAS
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES TO PASS ON
THE ROLL CALL. THIRTY ONE NINETY
THREE CHAO INFORMATION SECURITY
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. THIRTY
ONE NINETY FIVE ACOSTA
MOTORCYCLE DRIVERS LICENSE
INFORMATION ITS MISSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
THIRTY TWO OH ONE DAILY CLEAN
TRUCK PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE
THIRTY TWO A SEVEN LIMON BROKERS
LEAD GENERATORS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO RESOURCES
AND UTILITIES.
HOW WE DOING HIRING THAT IT IS
HEREBY LEVIN?
ALRIGHT A. B. SEVENTIES
SEVENTEEN SIXTY
STEINORTH DOGS IN STATE PARKS
YOU PASS IS AMENDED TO DELETE
ALL PROVISIONS AND HAD A
REQUIREMENT TO PERFORM AN
INVENTORY.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
MURATSUCHI OFFSHORE OIL LEE
SEEMED TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
BERMAN.
SEC EIGHTEEN OH FOR BERMAN.
I'M SORRY IF YOU CAN BELIEVE
THAT PART OUT.
EACH YOU NO FOR BERMAN SEQUENCE
YOU PASS ON A. B. ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA
OFFICE OF OUTDOOR RECREATION DO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT MCCARTY
CONSERVATION CORPS DO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
NO.
LET LET ME LET ME GO BACK
EIGHTEEN KNOW FOR BERMAN WAS IN
A ROLL CALL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
EDUARDO GARCIA. WAS IN A ROLL
CALL.
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT MCCARTY
WAS IN IRAQ CALL.
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
MAIENSCHEIN RECYCLING PROJECTS
DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
DELETE REFERENCES TO THE GDR AT
FUNNY LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE EDUARDO
GARCIA A. B. THIRTY TWO
INVESTMENT PLAN DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SPECIFY
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT IS GIVEN
FOR AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS LIKE
IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX AMOUNT FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES DO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE WOULD
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UNIVERSAL
SERVICES DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN OUR
GUYS GARCIA LOW CARBON FUELS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE
FURTHER DETAIL ON THE PILOT
PROPRIOCEPTIVE IT'S OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE KANSEN CHU
SOUTH BAY ODOR TASK FORCE DO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE MATHIS
WATER WASTEWATER LOANS AND
GRANTS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIFTY COPY AT A SMALL
SYSTEM WATER CONT. CONSOLIDATION
DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS REPLACE
A TREASURE WITH THE STATE
CONTROLLER MAKE A TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATION ABSTAINED.
JUST AN OVERLY REPLACE THE
TREASURE WITH STATE CONTROL IN
THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY FIFTY THREE QUIRK
HARMFUL TOXINS HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY SIXTY EDUARDO GARCIA
ADVANCE PAYMENTS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE AYE RW MP
PROVISIONS.
BACKED UP WITH REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING.
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR GLORIA ADVANCE
PAYMENTS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ALLOW ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR
PROJECTS OVER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AS PASS. AS SPECIFIED
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY SEVENTY TWO QUIRK WATER
POLLUTION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN LIMON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ELECTRICITY RATES
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINETY ONE GRAYSON
PRESCRIBED BURNS DO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF MEMBERS ON THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROVIDE THE INSURANCE
POLL IS ONLY REQUIRED IF FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE. REAL CHOIR
CONCERTS.
INSULT CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN OUT
OF SANTA CLAUS THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY NINETY FOUR KALRA
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES DO
PASSED WITH.
I TO BE RECALLED.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY QUIRK
WILDFIRES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX EGGMAN
FORESEE COURT PROGRAM TO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EVEY CHARGING NEEDS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY NINE SANTIAGO LEAD
CLEANUP DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CHANGE A FUNDING SOURCE TO THE
LEAD ACID BATTERY CLEANUP PLAN.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE O'DONNELL SHARK SAFETY
MONITORING TO PASS ON IN APRIL
CALL.
TWENTY ONE NINETY FIVE CHAO OUT
OF STATE NATURAL GAS TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO
OH EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY ARE PSU
PROCUREMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN AMOUNT
GREEN BUSINESS PROGRAM DO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TO
FORTY ONE RUBIO THE OPEN
TRANSPARENT WATER DATA ACT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY EIGHT
BERMAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RENEWABLE PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
GIPSON SALES CITY WATER SYSTEMS
DO PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY WATERFOWL HABITAT
DO YOU PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN ONE CARDIO WATER
USE EFFICIENCY TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
SALAS GIGI R. F. REPORT ON
PUBLIC HEALTH TO PASS ON AND A
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE CUTTY OF
VEHICLE MISSIONS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO LIMIT THE FUTURE FEE
INCREASES TO CERTAIN FACTORS
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY FOUR OF FOUR DONALD OIL
TRUST FUND YOU PASS ON ANY ROLL
CALL TWENTY FOUR OH SEVENTEEN
BATTERY RECYCLING ADVISORY GROUP
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE MARK
STONE MONARCH BUTTERFLY RESCUE
PROGRAM TO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STEAMY.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY ONE. LEVER
SITE HAD.
MUNA BUTTERFLIES IT LIKE MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
ONE.
WHEN THIS WHOLE SORRY WEBER HELP
IF WE.
INTERVENOR COMPENSATION HOLDING
COMMITTEE YOU'RE A.
SEE WHAT HAPPENS I TRIED TO ASK
YOU CARMEN. TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE FRAZIER ABANDON VESSELS DO
PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SEVEN GRAY S. C. GLAD
TO PASS AS AMENDEDDELETE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR NOTIFICATION B.
THIRTY EIGHT BEFORE
DETERMINATION IS MADE. REVISED
REQUIREMENTS FOR INDUSTRIAL LIKE
LAND USES AND MAKE VARIOUS OTHER
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE GALLAGHER R. THREE ADVISORY
GROUP DO PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR QUIRK
HAZARDOUS WASTE TESTING DO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS TO MAKE BILL
CONTINGENT ON AVAILABILITY OF
NON STATE FUNDS ACTED OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THREE BLOOM
CONVENIENCE SOUNDS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. TWENTY FIVE OH ONE
KANSEN CHU WATER DISTRICT
CONSOLIDATION TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN
RAY AS ELECTRICAL GAS
CORPORATIONS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE WOULD
ILLEGAL CANNABIS ON PUBLIC LANDS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR AND LIVE
MY OWN ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
GRANTS TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO EXEMPT THE GRANT GUIDELINES
FROM EPA AND REQUIRE THE USE OF
SPECIAL FUNDS ECOTYPE ON A BEEF
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN CARILLO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LIFELINE
OVERSIGHT BOARD DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE NINETY
PERCENT PARTICIPATION ALL THAT
GETS OUT ON AND. BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO
MUNICIPAL SEWER SIT MUNICIPAL
SEWER SYSTEMS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO DELETE THE PILOT PROJECT IN
THE REPUBLICANS ARE STINGING.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE GALLAGHER
STREAMBED ALTERATION AGREEMENTS
DO PASSES MENDED TEN STEP
REQUIRED DFW TO DEVELOP GENERAL
AGREEMENT SECONDS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE WOULD
FORCED HEALTH DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO DELETE THAT FUNDING CAP AND
REFERENCES TO GIGI ARE AFFECT
ITS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX OF SIX FONG HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITY PERMITS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO MAKE THE PERMIT
FEE CAP CONTINGENT ON THE
SOLVENCY OF THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN CARILLO
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES FOR JUST A
BEYOND USE TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN KALRA
MIGRATORY BIRDS MIGRATORY NOT
GAME BIRD TREATY ACT INCIDENTAL
TAKE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ARE BASED ON CURRENT
INFORMATION. PROVIDE SELF
CERTIFICATION MEETS COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND SPECIFY THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY FEDERAL
PERMITS ARE ISSUED THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE
ARAMBULA WATER RIGHTS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE DIVERSION
OF WATER FOR GROUND WATER
STORAGE BE CONSISTENT WITH ALL
EXISTING PERMITS ACTED OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO COURT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UNIVERSAL
SERVICE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY
THE PORT FREEZE IS FOR EXACTLY
SIXTY DAYS TO SIMPLIFY THE
RECERTIFICATION PROCESS. TO
ALLOW FOR ONLINE ENROLLMENT WITH
E. SIGNATURE AND TO REMOVE THE
NINETY SIX NINETY PERCENT
PARTICIPATION GOAL THAT GETS OUT
OF THE NINETY.
WITH THE WITH THE ROLL CALL.
NINETY PERCENT.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY KILEYFREE
HUNTING DAYS HOLDING COMMITTEE
WILD FOR FIRE STUDY HOLDING
COMMITTEE. TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE QUIRK NATURAL GAS FIRED
GENERATING UNITS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE CPUC TO
CONDUCT ITS ASSESSMENT THROUGH
AN EXISTING PROCEEDING. AND
CONSULT WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND REPRESENTATIVES
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES AND CCA'S
AND TO DELETE THE REVENUE
REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS OUT. WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
GALLAGHER WATERFOWL HABITAT DO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO LAND
IDLED BY WATER TRANSFERS
.
THOUGH THE MAKING AND THAT'S
GONNA GET OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX LEVINE
A. B. THIRTY TO STUDY HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
CHEN.
PLUMBING AND FIX YOUR LOAN
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX BERMAN
BOUGHT A BILL MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PAYMENTS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
QUIRK LET FISHING TACKLE TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REVISE STUDY
REQUIREMENTS INSTEAD REQUIRE DTS
SEE. TO REAP REVIEW EXISTING
RESEARCH AND DATA AND REGULATORY
EFFORTS LIKE IT'S OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FIVE WILD
PIGS BY MISTER BIGELOW DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REVISE THE
DEFINITION OF FREE ROAMING AND
FERAL PIG IN EUROPEAN WILD BOAR
THAT GETS OUT OF IT ROLL CALL.
OTHERS IN THE. OTHERS OF ITS
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY WHY LOW MOAN
SMALL BUSINESS CUSTOMER ENERGY
PROGRAMS DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. TWENTY THIRTY TWO DOLLY
BATTERY RECYCLING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE PROGRAM
PROGRAM INSTEAD REQUIRED DTS
SEED TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ACT
IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY
FORTY TWO BIGELOW WOOD PRODUCTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR LIMON COSTA OIL
SPILLS DE PASSES MINUTES DELETE
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
INSTEAD REQUIRE DFW TO. REQUEST
THE PARTICIPATION OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IN THE B. CDC IN THE
PROCESS LIKE IT'S OUT ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY TWO QUIRK
MOSQUITO PEST CONTROL DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL ARE
CONTINGENT UPON ON STATE FUNDING
LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY SIX KILEY
STATE PARKS FIRE REDUCTION.
STATE PARKS FIRE HAZARD
REDUCTION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY NINE OH A BERMAN TIRE
RECYCLING FEET TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY NINE TEN
WORD TELECOMMUNICATIONS NATURAL
DISASTER REPORTS TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL. TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
FRIEDMAN FIRE SAFETY TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY FOUR MARK
STONE LEAD PAINT HAZARD
REDUCTION DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN GALLAGHER
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR WATER
INNOVATION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE NINETY BLOOM FLAME
RETARDANT MATERIALS DO PASSED TO
REQUIRE THE BUREAU TO REIMBURSE
DE TSC FOR COSTS AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS ACT IT
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THREE ZERO ZERO NINE QUIRK
PETE FEED YOU PASS WITH AN
AMENDMENT TO INCREASE THE PER
GALLON FEE FROM ONE DOLLARS TO
DEFER TO DOLLARS. THAT GET OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL AB THIRTY
FIFTEEN CAMBIADO MARINE TERMINAL
OPERATIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY FORTY FIVE GALLAGHER
STATE WATER PROJECT COMMISSION
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY ONE ELEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA TELECOMMUNICATIONS
UNIVERSAL SERVICES HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SIX HOLDEN
OIL AND GAS WELL TESTING DO YOU
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO PERFORM THE
TESTING IN ADDIS SUNSET CLAUSE.
THAT GETS OUT.
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY TWO OF SIX FRIEDMAN
WATER METERS DO PASS.
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN ARAMBULA SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE THE
PROVISIONS REGARDING THE
PRIORITIZATION OF ACQUISITIONS.
THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TO FRIEDMAN
ZERO EMISSIONS BUILDINGS AND
SOURCES OF HEAT ENERGY TO PASS
ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
THIRTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
MURATSUCHI NATURAL RESOURCES DO
PASSED WITH TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
ACT IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
AB SEVEN.
SEVENTY FIVE AYE MAK MISTER
MURATSUCHI WAS A B. ROLL CALL.
ALRIGHT.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE LOW GEARS
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT TO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO LOW MINOR ENHANCEMENTS TO
CARE IS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE LOW
OVERSIGHT OF PRESCRIPTION PASSED
PADS DO PASS ON AND YOU WILL
CALL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY MAIENSCHEIN
IMPORTATION OF DISEASE DOGS AND
CATS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE THE REQUIREMENT FOR CD
PHD INVESTIGATE OUTBREAK SECONDS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
MAIENSCHEIN RESOURCE FAMILIES
PILOT PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO LIMIT THE PILOT TO UP TO FIVE
VOLUNTEER COUNTIES.
REQUIRE PARTS THINK HOW YOU
FIRST SEEK TO HIGHER SOCIAL
WORKERS MAKE OTHER CLAN FIGHTING
CHANGES LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE
GIPSON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORT VEHICLE.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORT TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SO BRING
CENTERS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
EIGHTEEN OH ONE AS AREA AND SEE
A MOVIE COMMISSION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENSURE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE EVIDENCE
BASED ON CHANGE THE COMMISSION
MEMBERSHIP PACKETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. EIGHTEEN SIXTY LIMON
COPAYMENTS FOR ORAL CHEMOTHERAPY
DRUGS DO PASS AS A MAN AND DID
TO LINE THE DOLLAR AMOUNT OF THE
COST SHARING CAP WITH A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY CAP THAT APPLIES
TO OTHER DRUGS THAT GETS ON TO
BE WELCOME.
EIGHTEEN A THREE WEBER.
CHILDCARE AND FOOD ASSISTANCE
FOR MILITARY FAMILIES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROVISION THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE MAIENSCHEIN CAL WORKS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY THAT SIXTEEN
KEMETIC CALENDAR DAYS MUST BE
WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO MAYES JOINT
PLAN TO END HUNDRED PACKETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE LIMON AL'S HAMMERS PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN HOLDING
COMMITTEE IN. NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BERMAN SOCIAL SERVICES
ELECTRONIC NOTIFICATIONS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WALDRON REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MEDI CAL OPIATE. ADDICTION
TREATMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR MAINTAINED
REGULATION DAY CAMPS HOLDING
COMMITTEE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
SANTIAGO EXPANDING LPS TO
CRITERIA INCLUDE MEDICAL
TREATMENT TO PASS ON ANY ROLL
CALL. NINETEEN NINETY MATHIS
INTEGRATE COMMUNITY LIVING
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO KANSEN CHU
CAL ARTS IMMUNIZATION
REQUIREMENTS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE TRANSPORTATION
PROVISIONS MAKE OTHER CONFORMING
CHANGES. THAT IS OUT ON ANY ROLL
CALL.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
PROTOCOLSFOR SAFE OPIOID.
DESCRIBING.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO CHANGE
PROTOCOL THE POLICY IN OUT
EXEMPTIONS DEFERRED TO THE BOARD
FOR DISCIPLINE REPLACE ANY
REPORTING WITH A SINGLE REPORT
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. REPLACE A
BLANK GOAL WITH CONTINUATION OF
THAT CURRENT DOWNWARD TREND AND
OTHER CHANGES THAT GETS OUT I'M
WITH REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MAIENSCHEIN
BOND AT FOR ELDER CARE
FACILITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY THREE NINE EDUARDO GARCIA
CLINIC REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS DO
PASOLINI ROLL CALL. TWENTY
THIRTY LIMON TOWERS DISABILITY
ACCOMMODATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS REQUIRE
THE NOTIFICATION PRECLUDED IN
ANY SYSTEM UPDATE MADE ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN NEXT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
BONTA AUTOMATE DRUG DELIVERY
SYSTEMS AND CLINICS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RAISE INITIAL MAXIMUM
FEE LEVELS ALLOW THE BOARD TO
LOWER RENEWAL FEES IF. LOWER
FEES CAN SUPPORT THE REGULATORY
COST THAT IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING TWENTY FORTY THREE
ARAMBULA PHOSTRIA FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM. DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE HOTLINE
PROVISIONS EXTEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES ACT OUT
WITHIN A ROLL CALL. TWENTY THREE
COOLEY TROM INFORM SYSTEM OF
CARE FOR FOSTER USE DO PASSED.
AS AMENDED ALSO TO.
TO ALSO REQUIRE THE INTERAGENCY
TEAM TO SUBMIT RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR PULLED FINANCE STRUCTURE
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWENTY ONE OH ONE
ACOSTA CAREGIVER CORPSE PILOT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN COURT CAL
RESPONSE ARE NOT NON CITIZENS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL TWENTY ONE
TWELVE SANTIAGO STATE
APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL CRISIS
MENTAL HEALTH CAN'T DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY THE
COMPONENTS ARE REQUIRED TO THE
EXTENT. CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL GRANT APPLICATION LIKE
IT'S OUT HONORING A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN COOLEY
SUPPLEMENTAL MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE PUBLIC
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
REUS MEDICAL MEDI CAL BLOOD LEAD
SCREENING LEVELS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE
REQUIREMENT DEVELOP A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. AND NARROW
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR INFORMING
MATERIALS CLARIFY DE H. C. S.
SHALL REQUIRE THE CONTRACTED
PLANS TO ENSURE SCREEN IS
CONDUCTED AN AD BLOOD LEVEL LED
SCREEN TESTED THE EXTERNAL
ACCOUNTABILITY SAT AT INTENT
LANGUAGE ANOTHER MINOR CHANGES.
PACKETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS OF
STAINING.
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR WALDRON
OPIOID A PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE RUBIO
RESOURCE FAMILY EMERGENCY
FUNDING HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE MAIENSCHEIN
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH SCREENING
TO PASS ON ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED PATTERSON
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR DRUG
COUNSELORS HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY TWO OH THREE GRADE MEDI
CAL PRIMARY CARE RATES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. TWENTY OH SEVEN
EGGMAN C. S. E. C. REPORT DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
DATA COLLECTION PROVISIONS THAT
GETS OUT IN A ROLL CALL. TWENTY
FOURTEEN RODRIGUEZ CERTIFICATION
OF SOBER LIVING HOLD HOMES LIVE.
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BLOOM CHANGES TO
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY REGULATION
DO PASS.
ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY THREE KALRA MEDI
CAL ASSISTED LIVING.
WEBER DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE TWO PROVISIONS RELATED TO
PROVIDER RATES.
THAT IS HOW THE REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINED.
TWENTY FORTY FOUR ACOSTA
REGIONAL CENTERS WAIVER REQUEST
PROCESS HOLDEN COMMITTEE TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN GIPSON FOSTER YOUTH
REPLACEMENT PRESERVATION PLANS
TO PASS AS AMENDED EXCLUDE
COUNTY PROBATION PLACEMENTS LIKE
IT'S OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWENTY TO SIXTY NINE
LACKEY CAL WORKS ITS EXTENSION
FOR NINETEEN YEAR OLD STILL IN
HIGH SCHOOL DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE ARAMBULA
MEDI CAL QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
MAKE IMPLEMENTATION FINANCE ON
SET A PROGRAM THAT REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL FUNDS CONTINGENT ON A
PREPARATION FOR THAT PURPOSE.
PACKETS OUT WITH A B. ROLL CALL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN KILEY M.
AT HIM EACH AS A OVERSIGHT
EXPANSION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINETY THREE RISKY UNTIL
A PARAMEDIC CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
STANDARDS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPLY THE DENIAL OF EMT ONE AND
MTV TO LICENSE APPLICATIONS NOT
THOSE PARAMEDICS. AND CLARIFY
CRIMES THAT ARE STILL
DISQUALIFYING THAT GETS OUT IN
THE B. ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINETY FIVE APPEL
MEDICAID ALL HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED WAIVER FROM MILITARY
FAMILIES HOLDING COMMITTEE OF.
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN ARAMBULA
HUNGER IMPACTED OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE RUBIO
INVESTIGATIONS AND COMMUNITY
CARE FACILITIES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX RUBIO
CAL WORKS WELFARE TO WORK
EXEMPTIONS FOR PARENTS OF VERY
YOUNG CHILDREN DO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT AS
THEIR ANYA SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CONTINUUM OF CARE
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY THREE
THIRTY ONE WEBER MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY WE JERRY REED
DETERMINATIONS FOR DEVELOP MANY
JUST DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
PERSONS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN GIPSON
TRANSITIONAL FOSTER CARE FOR
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEAR OLDS
WITH DELAYED COURTS PROCEEDINGS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FRIEDMAN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO BURKE
BRACKET SCREENING COVERAGE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE A
CLINICAL CRITERIA INSTEAD ALIGN
COVERAGE WITH FEDERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS LIKE IT'S OUT ON
A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN BERMAN
ONE PAGE AMENDED DEATH
CERTIFICATES
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY
THE DEPARTMENT SHALL INCLUDE
THIS.
FUNCTIONALITY IN THE NEXT MAJOR
UPGRADE OR REPLACEMENT OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
LIKE IT'S OUT ON ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY HOLDEN
TESTING DRINKING WATER FOR LEAD
IN CHILDCARE FACILITIES DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO MAKE CLEAR FINE
CHANGES THAT GETS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
ARAMBULA COVERAGE OF MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. DRUGS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO EXERT MEDI
CAL LIMITED TREATMENT FOR OPIOID
ADDICTION AND ALL OF OPIOID
OVERDOSE REVERSAL. ENUMERATE
COVERED DRUGS STRIKE PRESUMPTION
MEDICAL NECESSITY IN AT A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET LIKE IT'S OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN WHAT MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD TERMINATION AND NON
RENEWAL OF MEDI CAL PLAN
CONTRACTS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
TERMINATE THE CONTRACT IN INSERT
THE CONTENT CONTENTS OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN. WITH
LANGUAGE AMENDED TO FURTHER
SPECIFY WHICH PLANS REQUIRED TO
NEGOTIATE WITH CALIFORNIA.
WITH COVER CALIFORNIA THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY ARAMBULA
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
AGED AND DISABLED TO PASS WITHIN
A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR BLOOM
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES DO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX MATHIS
MEDI CAL GROUND AMBULANCE
READING CHRIS HOLDEN COMMITTEE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT GIPSON
COMPUTER ACCESS FOR DEPENDENT
JUVENILES THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE KALRA
SHARING CONTRACT INFORMATION
HOME CARE OF AIDS WITH LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO IMPLEMENT.
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY SIX
MONTHS LIKE IT'S OUT OF YOUR
CALL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
FRIEDMAN HEALTH INSURANCE
AFFORDABILITY TAX CREDIT. DO
PASS AS AMENDED MAKE
AVAILABILITY OF THE TAX CREDIT
GIVING YOUR CONTENTION ON THE
APPROPRIATION OF F. TB
TICKETMASTER THE CREDIT LIMIT
ELIGIBILITY TO THE RANGE OF FOUR
HUNDRED TO SIX HUNDRED PERCENT
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. IN
OUT A SEVEN YEAR SUNSET IN AN
ALLEY O. EVALUATION AFTER FIVE
YEARS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINED.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO WOULD
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH INSURANCE OPTION DO PASS
ON ANY ROLL CALL. TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SIX MCCARTY MEDI CAL
REBATES FOR OPIOID OPIOID DRUGS
DO PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE ARAMBULA
MEDICAL LOSS RATIOS TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL. TWENTY FIVE
VOTE TO LET HEALTHCARE PAYMENT%
DATABASE TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN WOULD IN
ARAMBULA ADVISORY PANEL ON
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FIVE DAVID CHIU HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR PERSONS
UNDER FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
SUBSIDIES CONTINGENT ON THE
PREPARATION FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY NINE BURKE
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY THROUGH A
WEEK GATEWAY DO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING. TWENTY
NINETY THREE GRAYSON
REIMBURSEMENT FOR AIR AMBULANCES
SERVICES DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ADJUST RATES TO A PERCENTAGE
MEDICARE THAT IS AT OR ABOVE THE
SUM OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN MEDI CAL
RATES PLUS SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
LEVELS. AND TO HOLD THE CONSUMER
HARMLESS FOR BALANCE BILLS FOR
COMMERCIALLY COVERED AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES THAT CAN TELL
THE REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY SIX SO TO MCCARTY
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY SERVICE
PROJECT IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY SIX
SO EIGHT MARK STONE FORMER
FOSTER USE ELIGIBILITY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY SIX POINT THREE HOLDEN
REGIONAL CENTER RATE ADJUSTMENTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX MULLIN SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE PROGRAM UPDATES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN
EDUCATION SUPPORT PAYMENTS FOR
CAL WHICH HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY SIX
FORTY THREE IRWIN.
YEAH.
COVERAGE MANDATE FOR DENTAL
ANASTASIA ANASTASIA HOLDING
COMMITTEE THANK YOU
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR
AGUIAR-CURRY HEALTH PROVIDER
BECOME. PAYMENT COMPLAINT
RESOLUTION PROGRAM.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO ELIMINATE
THE REQUIREMENT TO ADJUDICATE
INDIVIDUAL CLAIMS REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO ROUTINELY ANALYZE
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO PAYMENT
PRACTICES IN REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. WALLINGFORD COMPLAINTS
USED TO SUBSTANTIATE A
DETERMINATION OF AN UNFAIR
PAYMENT PRACTICE.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO BURKE IN A PADDED PRACTICE
FOR CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWENTY SEVEN OH TO
MCCARTY TRES LINE REGISTRY HOLD
IN COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN FRIEDMAN
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY FALLING CAL
WORKS TRANSITION TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FOUR RADIUS
R. C. F. E. REFERRAL AGENCIES
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE KALRA INGREDIENT
LABELING FOR PROFESSIONAL
COSMETICS DO PASS.
FRIEDMAN.
ON A ROLL CALL LOOK AT THAT.
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
MAIENSCHEIN TIMELINES FOR
HOSPITAL LIFE'S LICENSURE
CHANGES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY OH FOR WALDRON STATES
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WORKFORCE
SCHOOLS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE GLORIA
ALLOWABLE ENTITIES FOR REVERTED
M. H. S. A FUNDS TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FORTY SIX GIPSON WORKING
GROUP FOR TRANSPLANTS AND
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. TWENTY FIFTY RUBIO
ONLINE SEE ANY TRAINING TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE SALAS
MEDI CAL TELEHEALTH SERVICES FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPLY TO COVERED
INDIVIDUAL OUTPATIENT COUNSELING
SERVICES. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO CREEL IHS HAS PEER TO PEER
TRAINING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
MAKE CLEAR FINING TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. TWENTY
SEVENTY FOURTH THURMOND AG
OVERSIGHT OF HOSPITAL SERVICE.
WITHDRAWALS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLE COUPLE.
TWENTY NINETY THREE WALDRON
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ANALYSIS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THAT YOUR
RIGHTS AND ONLY WHEN APPLICABLE
PACKETS OUT ON ANY WILL CALL.
TWENTY NINETY FIVE ARAMBULA DATA
COLLECTION PRIMARY CARE SPENDING
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY NINE OH
FIVE ACOSTA FOSTER YOUTH
ENRICHMENT GRANTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY ONE O'DONNELL
REQUIRE REPORTING OF AMBULANCE
PATIENT OFFLOAD TIME DO PASS AS
AMENDED ELIMINATE THE STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE LANGUAGE
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
OF STAINING. TWENTY NINE SIXTY
FIVE ARAMBULA MEDI CAL
LEGIBILITY REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS DO PASS AS
AMENDED EXPAND ELIGIBILITY TO
YOUTH ADULTS AGES NINETEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE INSTEAD OF ALL
ADULTS LIKE IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY SIX QUIRK
STATE AGENCIES COLLABORATION FOR
CHILDHOOD LEAD TESTING TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL.
THREE ZERO ZERO SIX MARK STONE
CHILD WELFARE WELFARE SERVICES
FOR DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
CHILDREN DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE ROLE OF COUNTY. DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING COORDINATOR
REQUIRED DSS TO ARE CLEVERLY
WITH THE STATE'S STAFF ACCESS
PROGRAM THAT GETS OUT ON THAT
YOU WILL CALL.
THIRTY THIRTEEN KANSEN CHU
ANIMAL PHYSICAL THERAPY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. THIRTY THIRTY THREE
MAIENSCHEIN STREAMLINING CAL
FRESH APPLICATIONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. THIRTY THIRTY NINE
HOLDEN CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS THAT STATE LICENSED
FACILITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR FRAZIER
REGIONAL CENTER INTEGRATED
COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE THIRTY SEVENTY SIX
THREE IS INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
LEGAL SERVICES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. THIRTY TWO GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HSS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY AND NARROW
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. THIRTY
EIGHTY SEVEN KALRA.
HEALTH CARE COST CONTAINMENT
COMMISSION.
IF THERE AUTHORS REQUEST AND THE
SPONSORS AND TO THIS CHAIR A. B.
THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN IS HELD ON
SUSPENSE I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THE WORK ON THIS ISSUE BUT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WORKING
FAMILIES CAN NO LONGER AFFORD
THE SKYROCKETING COST. OF
HEALTHCARE
NO CALIFORNIAN CAN THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TO ADDRESS OF WE DO NOTHING IT
WILL BE TO BRING DOWN OUR
ECONOMY. AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
HOLDING IT DOES NOT STOP PEOPLE
FROM WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A HUGE
MISTAKE.
THANK YOU.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN MULLIN STATE
REGISTRATION FOR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY TWO
YEARS ENSURE THOSE WITH. AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER TITLE WHO ARE
NOT CERTIFIED IN A COVERED UNDER
CBA RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
YEARS TO RENEGOTIATE TITLE
CHANGES AND JOB DESCRIPTIONS.
AND TO SPECIFY LOW REPLY PAYMENT
FROM FEE REVENUE. THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING
THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD SUNSET
EXTENSION DO PASS ON AND YOUR
ROLE CALL. THIRTY ONE FORTY
ARAMBULA HEALTH INSURANCE COST
SHARING SUB SUBSIDIES FOR
PERSONS UNDER FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL.
POVERTY LEVEL HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE RUBIO
CHILD LIFE SPECIALIST SERVICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX WALDRON ICWA.
FEDERAL CONFORMITY DO PASS IS
MEANT TO BE CLARIFIED AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
ON AND HE WILL CALL. THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED KALRA SS I SS PICCOLA DO
PASS AS AMENDED A STRIKE THAT
THE INDEXING PROVISION THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS ASKING.
COOL.
ALRIGHT ALMOST THERE
.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
EIGHTEEN NO ONE BY MISTER AS
ARIANNA GOT OUT.
ON OF THE ROLL CALL WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON EDUCATION ATB'S
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE O'DONNELL
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTER GRANTS TO PASS IS AMENDED
TO READ DIRECT STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING TO HIGH SCHOOL PROGRAMS
LIKE IT'S OUT ON ANY ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN.
OH THAT DOES NOT I'M SORRY.
WRONG WRONG WRONG WHEN. THAT
THAT SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE BY
O'DONNELL GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINED.
YOU GUYS LIKE CT.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ.
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS AND DRILLS.
THAT GETS OUT AND HE ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR MCCARTY
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION FOR LOW
INCOME FOR YOUR OLD SACKETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE KANSEN CHU
POST SECONDARY INFORMATION
SCHOOLS HOLDING COMMITTEE
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN CERVANTES
CALIFORNIA KICKSTART MY FUTURE
LOAN PROGRAM.
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM DO PASS
ON OF THE ROLL CALL.
EIGHTEEN NO THREE CHOI CAREER
PLACEMENT JOB SERVICES HOLDING
COMMITTEE EIGHTEEN FIFTY
CALDERON FINANCIAL AID SHOPPING
SHEET DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE INSTITUTIONS TO RIDE THE
SHOPPING SHEET WHEN ADMITTING
STUDENTS. AND AT A CLEAR FIND IT
AMENDMENTS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE BONTA FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
IN CHARTER SCHOOLS D. PASSES
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
BY YOUR HAVE AUTHORIZED THERE'S
A PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WHEN POSSIBLE ON LIMIT CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL LIMIT TO.
CLASSROOM BASED ARTICLES THAT
GETS OUT WITH THE ROLL CALL.
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE CALDERON
INCOME BASED REPAYMENT PROGRAMS
FOR DREAMERS DO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING. NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE IRWIN COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FUNDING FOR TUTORING DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX LOW HIGHER EDUCATION
PLANNING OFFICE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
O'DONNEL ALTERNATIVE GRADE
ELEVEN ASSESSMENT DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LADY OPTION BY ONE
YEAR SITE FEDERAL CODE FOR
REQUIRED ACCOMMODATIONS AND MAKE
OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE CHOI A POST
SECONDARY STUDENT HOUSING A MEAL
PLAN COSTS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ONLY REQUIRE SEPARATE LISTING OF
HOUSING AND MEAL PLANS. THAT
GETS OUT AND HE WILL CALM
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I HAD
GONZALEZ FLETCHER LIMITS TO
COLLECTION OF DEBTS IN SCHOOL DO
PASSED ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE WALDRON
SCHOOL SECURITY ASSESSMENT
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWO THOUSAND TO ARAMBULA MONGER.
MODEL CURRICULUM HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN RARE STUDENT AID
FORM INSTRUCTION DO PASSED THE
ROLL CALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO
KANSEN CHU MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND SCHOOLS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
REVEALED MENTAL HEALTH PRACTICES
IN SCHOOLS ACT IT OUT ON A BE
WILL CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY ONE O'DONNELL
SCHOOL FACILITY CONTRACTOR PRE
QUALIFICATION TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FORTY ONE CUP
BIO DIVERSITY IN UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUEST THE UC AND
PARTNER FIRMS LAUNCH EMERGING
PARK. MANAGER PROGRAMS REMOVE
REQUEST TO SEND INDIVIDUALS TO
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM LIKE IT'S
GONNA BE A WELCOME.
TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN GALLAGHER ARM
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY NINETY EIGHT
MCCARTY AFTER SCHOOL COMPUTER
CODING. GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE SERMON LGBTQ TEACHER
TRAINING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
TRAINING AT ANY TIME DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL. TWENTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THURMOND SPECIAL EDUCATION
GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE
FRAZIER INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES SERVICE
COORDINATION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REQUIRE PLAN TO INCLUDE PLANS
FOR LINKING DATA. ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
THURMOND STEMMONS SCHOOLS
INITIATIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PROVIDE GRANTS FOR STEM TEACHERS
LIKE IT'S OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY CHAU TO GRAY NEW UNIVERSE
USE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE DO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY BONTA COLLEGE
STUDENT ATHLETE RIGHTS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO NARROW PROVISIONS
TO PROGRAMS GENERATE REVENUE
OVER TEN MILLION ANNUALLY.
REQUIRE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO ATHLETES AND
ESTABLISH COMPLAINT PROCEDURES
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT WHAT
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS AFFECTED BY
WILDFIRES DO PASS AS AMENDEDTO
CONFORM TO THE EDUCATION CODE ON
A ROLL CALL. TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
JONES SAWYER TEST MONEY A MINOR
WITNESSES IN AGREE JUST
MISCONDUCT CASES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DESIGNATE A PARENT AS
A DEFAULT SUPPORT PERSON THAT
GETS OUT ON IN IRAQ CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE QUIRK SILVA
FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS INSERTED
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE OBERNOLTE STEM
SEALS ON HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE QUIRK SILVA
HAVE MATCHING STATE FUNDS FOR
SCHOOL LUNCH EQUIPMENT TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL. TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
NINE WEBER LEAVE FOR PREGNANT
PARENTING STUDENTS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL TWENTY NINETY TWO
AGUIAR-CURRY CHILD CARE WRITTEN
CREASES IN GRANTS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. SANTIAGO COMEY COLLEGE CAL
GRANT EXTENSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE QUIRK SILVA TELEHEALTH
GUIDELINES FOR SCHOOL TWENTY
THREE FIFTEEN I'M SORRY.
LET ME DO IN THE RIGHT ORDER
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN QUIRK SILVA
TELL HEALTH GUIDELINES FOR
SCHOOL DO PASS THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY RODRIGUEZ
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FOOD. BANK
PARTNERSHIPS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE WEBER
UNIVERSAL CALIFORNIA OUTSOURCE
CONTRACT REPORTING DO PASSED THE
ROLL CALL. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR KILEY FREE SPEECH POLICY
THE POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX RUBIO OCCUPATIONAL
AND PHYSICAL THERAPY CREDENTIAL
REPORT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE EDUARDO
GARCIA AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
SCHOOLS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN YOU WANT
THURMOND SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
GRADS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN RUBIO
DREAM RESOURCE LIAISONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED ENCOURAGE LAYS ON
THAT THE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE REGION. THAT
GETS OUT ON THE BEALL CALL
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NINE VOEPEL
INCOME SHARING AGREEMENTS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
O'DONNELL TASK ORDER PROCUREMENT
PILOT TO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING TWENTY FOUR NINETY
EGGMAN SOCIAL WORKER PILOT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIVE A FIVE SANTIAGO CSU
OVERSIGHT REPORTING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LET ME ONGOING CSU
AUDITS. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STADIUM TWENTY
FIVE FOURTEEN THEIR MENTAL
LANGUAGE IN SCHOOLS GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN MCCARTY
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
PATTERSON BUT CREDIT POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
CUNNINGHAM'S CONTINUANCES FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION CASES DO PASS
A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN
ARAMBULA UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS MEDICAL EDUCATION TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
AS AMENDED TO MODIFY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS DESCRIBE
FEASIBILITY OF EXPANDING PROGRAM
TO REMOVE FUNDING CAN CONDITION.
GET OUT ON A ROLL CALL THE TWICE
SIX A ONE WEBER SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOLS DO
PASSED THE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
SIX OH NINE O'DONNELL SCIENTISTS
TO TEACHER PATHWAYS PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE WEBER
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS FOR LOWEST
PERFORMING PUPILS SUBGROUPS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE BERMAN
SUICIDE PREVENTION TRAINING
SCHOOLS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE COUNTY OFFICES OF ED. TO
SUPPLY TRAINING MATERIALS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT GET OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN WEBER
PROHIBITIONS ON STUDENTS
SECLUSION IN RESTRAINTS DO
PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
THREE GIPSON SKIN AUTHOR GRANTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SIX JONES SAWYER SCHOOL
STAFF MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SIX ANYONE JONES SAWYER
INFORMATION TRAINING FOR SCHOOLS
ON TROM INFORMED CARE DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. TWENTY SEVEN UP FOR
DONALD REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SENATOR SPECIAL ED
YOU PASS A ROLL CALL. TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWO MEDINA
FINANCIALLY FOR NATIONAL GUARD
AND STATE MILITARY RESERVE
MEMBERS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN HOLDEN
COLLEGE IN ATHLETE NOTIFICATIONS
AND PROHIBITING HAITIAN
PROHIBITION I'M SORRY A
RETALIATION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ADD CLARIFYING AND INTENT
LANGUAGE A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE
O'DONNELL ENGLISH LEARNER
PROTOCOL DEVELOPMENT TO PASS A
ROLL CALL TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
ONE EGGMAN HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES FONDUE PASSED THE
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TO MEDINA
ETHNIC STUDIES HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR COPY AT
ALL CALVARY STATE UNIVERSITY
HOUSING PILOT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE RUBIO
LACTATION ROOMS AND INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION DO PASS AS
AMENDED REQUEST YOU SEE
PARTICIPATE REQUIRE SEEMS TO BE
ADDED. TO LACTATION ROOMS ONLY
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
THAT PASSES WITH WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY EIGHT L. EIGHT MURATSUCHI
BASE RATE INCREASE TO LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA DO PASS.
B. ROLL CALL MURATSUCHI SCHOOL
PESTICIDES REPORT TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL
INSIDE THAT NUMBER OF THAT LAST
MURATSUCHI WAS TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN HOLDEN
STUDY OF HIGH TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
DIVERSITY TO PASS AS AMENDED
INCLUDE GENDER IN LGBT CUTE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND ASSIGN THE
STUDY TO A RESEARCH CENTER AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ALONG. WITH LA.
THAT IT'S GONNA BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY THREE MEDINA S.
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES LIAISON
FOR CAMINO COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THURMOND
ONLINE CHILD CARE PORTALS.
WE.
I'M AS ONE.
I'M SORRY THERE IS A PAGE
MISSING AND MY THING.
SO LET'S GO BACK TO WE JUST DID
HOLDEN AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY.
RACE EVERYTHING OUT BEEPED AFTER
THAT
AB TWENTY TWENTY MCCARTY
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SCHOOLS DO PASSES
AMENDMENT AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
THE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO VET. SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS AND PROVIDE
SURVEYS AT NO CHARGE THE SCHOOL
THAT GETS OUT ON THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE HOLDEN
CHARTER SCHOOL DUAL ENROLLMENT
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY NINE
THIRTY THREE MEDINA COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICES LAYS ON FOR
COMMITTEES COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THURMAN ONLINE
CHILD CARE PORTALS DO PASS AS
AMENDED CLARIFY ONLINE PORTAL
PLANNING AND REQUIREMENTS OF
ONLINE PORTAL THAT GETS OUT AND
HE WELCOMED.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY MCCARTY.
WELL IT WAS IN THE WRONG ORDER
SEE.
WHEN BURKE.
OKAY.
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY NINE BURKE.
CRITICAL EDUCATION DIPLOMACY ALL
DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
THREE THOUSAND EIGHT BURKE
TUITION WAIVERS FOR E. TWO VISA
HOLDERS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THIRTY FORTY EIGHT IRWIN
AUTOMATED TEACHER MRS SIGN MY
MONITORING HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THIRTY EIGHTY NINE SERMON
FINANCIAL AID FOR FOSTER USED TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR PHOSTRIA UP JUST
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF AGE AND
MAKING FUNNY. SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION THAT GETS OUT IN A
ROLL CALL THIRTY NINETY SIX
RUBIO SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT CARD.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION OUT SCHOOL
FACILITIES MATERIALS IN OUT
INTENT LANGUAGE LIKE IT'S OUT ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX O'DONNELL
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
INCREASES.
DO PASS ON AN A ROLL CALL TWELVE
THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE LEVINE
SUMMER CAL GRANTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AMENDED TO LIMIT SOME
RIGHT CREDITS TO FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN O'DONNELL
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZED
HERS TO PASS AS AMENDED MAKE
CHANGES TO NETWORKS ADVISORY
BOARD AND MAKE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. THAT GETS OUT ON
B. ROLL CALL. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX MEDINA BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUTE COLLEGES DO PASSED THE
ROLL CALL.
AB THIRTY TWO OH FIVE O'DONNELL
SCHOOL DOOR LOCKS DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL.
THIRTY TWO THIRTEEN BONTA
FINANCIAL E. DISBARMENT
DISBURSEMENTS AND COST OF
ATTENDANCE HOLDING COMMITTEE.
THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE KILEY
ADDITION AGREEDELEVEN
ASSESSMENTS TO LOCAL COUNT BILLY
INDICATORS TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
NEXT WEEK I GO TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
ALRIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE
CUNNINGHAM HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RESTRAINING ORDERS DO PASS A
ROLL CALL.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WEBER
CHECKBOX ON CRIME REPORTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE BONTA
CANNABIS CONVICTION EXPUNGEMENT.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
DOJ TO NOTIFY PROSECUTORS
INCIDENT COURTS AND WHILE
ELIGIBLE PERSONS ALLOW MORE TIME
FOR PROSECUTORS TO REVIEW CASES
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT THE DOJ
NOTIFY ELIGIBLE PERSONS AND MAKE
OTHER CHANGES. THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO CERVANTES
HUMAN TRAFFICKING COMMUNICATION
WITH MINOR TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL.
NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD PRICE
GOUGING OF RENTAL HOUSING DURING
AN EMERGENCY DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SPECIFY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES WILL PRIOR
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PRICE GOUGING LAW. ON RELEVANT
WEBSITES LIKE IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN BONTA
VOLUNTARY FARMS DO NOT SELL LIST
DO PASS AS AMENDED IN STE
REQUIRE THE DOJ TO REPORT ON
OPTIONS FOR ALLOWING A PERSON TO
REGISTER THEMSELVES AS
INELIGIBLE TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM.
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE LACKEY
EVALUATION OF SEAT DC ARE
PROGRAMS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE STEINORTH
VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM PET
BOARDING COST YOU PASS A ROLL
CALL. NINETEEN FORTY MCCARTY
PAROLE REINTEGRATION CREDIT
PROGRAM DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN FORTY JONES SAWYER
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES IN
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. NINETEEN FORTY NINE
SANTIAGO FLAMETHROWER WARNING
LABEL FOLDING COMMITTEE.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT LOW MENTAL
HEALTH FIREARM RESTRICTIONS DO
PASS YEAR OLD LAW.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE SANTIAGO LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPORTING TO CHILD
ABUSE CENTRAL INDEX DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES REPORT SUBSTANTIATE
CASES TO BE USE TO THE INDEX IF
THEY HAD IT HERE.
TO VARIOUS YOU PROCESS
REQUIREMENTS SECOND NOW WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
TWENTY THIRTEEN CUNNINGHAM
NOTIFICATION PUBLIC INFORMATION
IN CRIME REPORTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
PRISON SECURITY ASSESSMENTS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE REPORTS
THE LEGISLATURE CONFIDENTIAL
REMOVE SECTIONS RELATING TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO DETERMINE HOW
FREQUENTLY TO CONDUCT THE
ASSESSMENT TO MAKE CONFORMING
CHANGES. PACKETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS OF STAINING.
TWENTY SEVEN D. EIGHT DAILY SEX
OFFENSES DURING PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES TO PASS A ROLL CALL
TWENTY EIGHTY NINE NINE OF
MATHIS SPONSOR FIREFIGHTER
BACKGROUND CHECKS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED BONTA VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAM PEER
COUNSELLING HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR RUBIO IN
BAKER VERTICAL PROSECUTION GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE WEBER
DEFENSE ATTORNEY ACCESS TO
CRIMINAL RECORDS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. TWENTY ONE THIRTY SIX
BONTA ALAMEDA COUNTY ASSESSMENT
PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE LOCAL MANDATE THAT
GETS OUT WITHIN A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
AGUIAR-CURRY VOTE IMPOUNDMENT TO
PASS A ROLL CALL TWENTY SIXTEEN
PATTERSON HUMAN TRAFFICKING
GRANT PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO QUIRK LOST
AND STOLEN FIREARM REPORTING DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
DOJ AUDIT REQUIREMENT FACTS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX PATTERSON
SECURITY SYSTEM FOR CRIME
VICTIMS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM PORTION OF THIS BILL
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY OF FIFTY THEY'RE MEANT.
NOW I KNOW I HAVE A DIFFERENT
QUESTION.
AND TWENTY FIFTY THURMOND AND
CAR SAY PARENTS WORKING GROUP
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY NINETY
GALLAGHER RESTRAINING ORDERS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SIX KILEY EXPANDED THREE
STRIKES LAW HOLDEN COMMITTEE
TWENTY THREE FIFTY NINE
MAIENSCHEIN VERTICAL PROSECUTION
GRANT PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY TWO GIPSON
FIREARM PARTS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REMOVE THE APPROPRIATION MAKE
OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FOUR TWELVE ARAMBULA
POLICE STATION GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHTEEN
CRIMINAL RECORD EXPUNGEMENT
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY ONE FLOOR BACKGROUND
CHECK.
SUBSEQUENT NOTIFICATIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND THEY
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD THAT
GETS OUT WITHIN A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE OH FOR LOW PEACE
OFFICER TRAINING ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
DO PASS AS AMENDED REMOVE THE
LOCAL MANDATE MAKE OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES.
TWENTY FIVE A SEVEN JONES SAWYER
THAT GOT OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN JONES
SAWYER BREASTMILK FEEDING
POLICIES IN COUNTY JAILS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO ENSURE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY ONLY TO
COUNTY JAILS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN JONES
SAWYER NARCOTICS REGISTRY
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY COOPER ILLEGAL CANNABIS
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE.
pSTONE INDIGENT PRISON INMATES
TO
PASS BEALL CALL TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX CHEN ORANGE COUNTY
PROPERTY CRIME TASK FORCE
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY RE S. IDENTIFYING VETERANS
IN COUNTY JAILS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE CASE
SUMMARY YOU REQUIREMENT. INSTEAD
REQUIRE GELS TO ASK DETAINEES
WHETHER THEY ARE VETERANS
DOCUMENT THE PERSON'S RESPONSE
AND SHARE THE INFORMATION WITH
SPECIFIED ENTITIES THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. TWENTY FIVE
NINETY NINE HOLDEN CRIMINAL
EXPUNGEMENT TO PASS AS AMENDED
REMOVE THE MANDATE ON COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SECOND OUT
ON IT YOU ROLL CALL. TWENTYSIX
FIFTY NINE COOLEY JUVENILE
RECORD ACCESS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN OH ONE RUBIO TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS AND SCHOOLS
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY SEVEN
NO SIX JONES SAWYER.
RE.
RE ENTRY I THINK THIS.
OKAY.
NOT DEATHLY MISSING AN EN. I'M.
RE ENTRY CASE CONFERENCES FOR
USE DISCHARGED FROM DJJ.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
PARTICIPATION OPTIONAL FOR
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS
LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR EGGMAN
PRISON INMATES DRIVER'S LICENSES
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY MIND AS
CRIMINAL THREATS HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT CARILLO
EDUCATION ALTERNATIVES PEACE
OFFER SO JUST PLAN HOLDING
COMMITTEE. TWENTY SEVENTY ONE
LOW FIREARMS FRIENDS ATTESTING
TO PASS AS AMENDED REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT TO TEST LET'S MAKE
OTHER CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SANTIAGO FARMS
TRANSFERABLE TO COMMITTEE.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE NAZARIAN
VIOLENT FELONIES DO PASS.
ON ANY ROLL CALL TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FIVE BONTA PARDON AND
COMMUTATION PANEL TO PASS. ON TO
BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT WEBER
DISPOSITION OF EVIDENCE IN
CRIMINAL CASES DO PASSES MANY
MAKE VARIOUS CHANGES PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO COURTS
AND LIMITS ARE PROVISIONS. THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO DALY
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING ON
EXPLOITED CHILDREN TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
GIPSON VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
IN JAIL TO PASS BEALL CALL.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN DAVID CHIU
REPORT AN UNTESTED SEXUAL
ASSAULT KIDS IN THE WINNER OF
THE SOCIAL MEDIA QUIT.
TWITTER IN ME.
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL TO
PASS.
AS AMENDED TO LIMIT TO AND
TESTING KITS.
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF TWEETS.
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY NINE RUBIO
FIREARMS PROHIBITED PERSONS TO
PASS WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINED.
WE KNEW. ALMOST AND
.
I RATE MY FAVORITES.
IT'S A MONEY OUT OF THIS
APPROACH HOW RIGHT HERE.
REVENUE AND TAXATION.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR
CALDERON.
FILM TAX CREDIT DO PASS AS
AMENDED WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS IN ADDING MISTER
NAZARIAN AS A CO AUTHOR. THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE QUIRK
SILVA DISASTER LOSSES TAX CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE JONES SAWYER
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS EXPENSE
DEDUCTION DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
NINETEEN UP FOR CERVANTES TAX
CREDIT FOR HIRING APPRENTICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. NINETEEN
FORTY TWO SANTIAGO CAL E. I. T.
C. OUT REACH HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SALAS CARL
MOYER GRANTS EXCLUSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
COMPANY AT A CHILD CARE EXPENSES
TAX CREDIT. DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CAP THE REFUND TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR ONE QUALIFYING
INDIVIDUAL ON FIVE HUNDRED FOR
TO CALL FINE INDIVIDUALS THAT
IT'S GONNA BE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY THIRTY NINE FONG CAL ABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS DEDUCTIONS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY FORTY TWO
STEINORTH GREEN WATER USE SYSTEM
TAX CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY SIXTY SIX MARK STONE EITC
HOLDING COMMITTEE. MELENDEZ
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BURKE BRIDGET
MASON GOLDEN STATE CREDIT
PROGRAM TO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
ABSTAINING.
AB TWENTY AND FIFTY THREE IRWIN
ABLE PROGRAM BOUNCES A MEANS
TESTED PROGRAMS HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
LACKEY DISABLED VETERANS
EXEMPTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIFTY NINE PATTERSON
STILLBIRTH TAX CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE HOLD INTERFERE MOBILE
GRANT EXCLUSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE OH THREE SERMON
PRIVATE PRISON TAX TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL TWENTY THREE TWELVE
EDUARDO GARCIA CALTRAIN COMPETES
TAX CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE TEEN
BORDER WALL ON ELIGIBILITY FOR
TAX BENEFITS TO PASS B. ROLL
CALL TWENTY THREE NINETY FOUR
BRO MILITARY RETIREE PAY
EXCLUSION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FOUR TEN GRAYSON LLC
ANNUAL TAX REDUCTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN CHOI TAX
PREFERENCE AT IT VENT CLOSURES
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT VOEPEL INCOME
EXCLUSION FOR EMPLOYER PAYMENTS
DISTANT LANDS HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY FIVE SENATE FOR BLOOM
SALES AND USE TAX EXEMPTION
VIDEO GAME INDUSTRY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN GRADE DEDUCTION FOR LABOR
ORGANIZED.
DEDUCTION FOR LABOR ORGANIZATION
DO IS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY CHEN INCOME
EXCLUSION SERVICE MEMBERS HOLDEN
COMMITTING. TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE FRET FRIEDMAN PROPERTY
TAXES DOMESTIC PARTNERS PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED BURKE
TRAINING PROGRAMS TAX CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE TWENTY SEVEN A
THREE MAYES TAX REFERENDUM CARE
SERVICES HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN FLORA
TAX RATE FOR FIREFIGHTERS
HOLDING COMMITTEE.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE GIPSON
CARRIED INTEREST TAX.
DO PASS AS AMENDED IT TO IT.
AT AN URGENCY CLAWED RE REFER TO
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY BURKE ANGEL
INVESTMENT TAX CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
THREE SANTIAGO RENTER'S CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE. TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE ROAD NET OPERATING LOSS
REFUND PROCESS DO YOU PASS ON
ANY ROLL CALL. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY GIPSON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE
TWEN I'M THIRTY TWO CHOI
EMPLOYMENT TAX RATE HOLDING
COMMITTEE.
TWENTY NINE THREE SIX NAZARIAN
FILM TAX CREDIT HOLDEN COMMITTEE
TWENTY NINE FORTY FIVE GALLAGHER
HARD OF HEARING EMPLOYEE TAX
CREDIT HOLD OF THE HOLD IN
COMMITTEE. TRYING I NINETY NINE
BONTA AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
REVELED IN COMMITTEE. THREE
THOUSAND FRIEDMAN RETAIL
HYDROGEN VEHICLE FIELD SALES TAX
EXEMPTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE
THIRTY TWENTY NINE ARAMBULA NEW
EMPLOYMENT TAX CREDIT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. THIRTY FIFTY SEVEN
QUIRK SILVA MUTUAL DITCH
COMPANY'S AND TAX STATUS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE.
THIRTY SEVENTY TWO DAVID CHIU
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE THIRTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN ACOSTA TAX CUT FROM
PLAYS WITH DISABILITIES HOLD
WITH COMMITTEE. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT CHEN TAX RATE FOR
SERVICE DOG EXPENSES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. THIRTY ONE FIFTY TO
DAVID CHIU WELFARE EXEMPTION
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING HOLDEN
COMMITTING THIRTY ONE FIFTY SIX
LACKEY CANNABIS TAXES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
FRIEDMAN SALES TAX HOLIDAY FOR
WATER EFFICIENCY PRODUCTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE THIRTY ONE
NINETY SEVEN BURKE SPACE FLIGHT
PROPERTY IN TAXES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. THIRTY TWENTY NINE
FRAZIER DISABLED VETERANS
EXEMPTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU OFFER PLANE